Hi, I’m David Baker from the University of Washington.
Today, I’m gonna talk about crowdsourcing protein folding.
So, as I described in my iBio seminars,
my group is working on predicting the structures
of naturally occurring proteins
and designing brand new protein structures.
And these calculations are very computationally intensive,
so a number of years ago
we had filled up every nook and cranny of my lab,
and the hallway next door,
with computer boxes
and were getting into trouble because we were heating up the building
and it was very expensive,
and we were… still didn’t have enough computing power
to accurately predict protein structures
or to design new proteins.
So, we started a project called Rosetta@Home,
which you can look up on the web,
and please join.
If you sign up for Rosetta@Home, you will…
when you’re not using your computer, a screensaver will appear,
and what that screensaver will show you
will be the course of a calculation,
a protein structure prediction calculation
or a protein design calculation,
that we’ve sent you.
And so, for every challenge that we have,
whether it’s predicting a protein structure
or designing a new protein,
we send the sequence out to…
out to you, if you become a Rosetta@Home volunteer,
and then Rosetta@Home volunteers
send us back automatically the solutions.
And those are… that’s really the workhorse of computation
in my research group.
And currently there are over 350,000 Rosetta@Home volunteers,
and I hope there’ll be one more after you listen to video.
And that, again, is really making…
enabling the research that we’re doing.
So, as part of Rosetta@Home,
we give feedback on the message boards
for the project about the…
about the progress of the research,
and participants write in and ask questions,
and we try to answer those questions.
I try and do it myself,
but I don’t do it probably as often as I should…
but… so, we have a dialogue with participants,
which has really been fun,
and has given me and others in my group
an opportunity to describe what we do to the general public.
Well, a number of years ago, Rosetta@Home volunteers wrote in and said,
we’re watching the screensaver,
we’re seeing the… we see the protein folding up,
but we’ve been watching it for long enough to think that the prot…
the computer is really not doing as well as it could.
If only I could get in there
and sort of guide the protein to fold up and…
I think I could get it to a better job…
a better job finding the lowest energy state.
So, this inspired us to team up with
a group in the Computer Science Department at the University of Washington
to develop a… basically, an interactive version of Rosetta@Home
called FoldIt.
Now, in FoldIt…
there’s a screenshot of FoldIt shown here.
You see the protein molecule that umm…
that we call the… each prob… of FoldIt,
each problem we’re working on we frame as a puzzle for FoldIt.
So, here you see the protein chain,
and one of the big innovations near the beginning,
as I described in my iBio seminar,
the… proteins fold to their lowest energy states,
but it wasn’t a very good game when you were competing to get a lower score.
So, we took the energy and multiplied it by -100,
so now the goal was to get a higher end… higher score…
higher scores are better, and it’s a com…
FoldIt is a competitive game, so you’re moving the protein around.
FoldIt computes the energy.
It’s basically an interface to Rosetta@Home,
so it’s computing the energy in the same way
that Rosetta does,
but rather than having the computer randomly search around,
you as a FoldIt player
are doing the search by moving the protein around.
Now, you don’t have to do it all by hand.
There are tools on the bottom left…
that are shown on the bottom left,
which are basically Rosetta algorithms
which you can call to help you,
which for example will find the nearest local minimum
or search for a different conformation of the side chains,
which are these stick-like structures coming off the backbone.
And the… Rosetta@Home only has access to the… to the…
these automated algorithms, whereas with FoldIt…
a FoldIt player… and you can go download FoldIt
right after you finish watching this…
and when you do this, you’ll use a combination of
your own intuition about where the low energy…
lowest energy state might lie
and these automated methods.
Now, this is… that…
what I’ve described so far is for a protein structure prediction problem,
but… but again, as I described in my iBio seminar,
we’re very excited now about designing
brand new proteins that never existed before
to address current day challenges.
And FoldIt players are indeed now designing new proteins.
So, in design puzzles,
you can change not only the… where…
the geometry of the protein, where the backbone is,
but you can change what amino acid is where —
you can change the sidechains.
And we’ve… I’ve been really amazed
at the wonderful things that FoldIt players
have done over the years,
and I’ll give you some highlights in the remainder of my talk.
And the really interesting… one of the…
the really interesting thing is that FoldIt players
have made new scientific discoveries,
and I’ll describe several of these.
The first discovery concerns determining the structure
of a protein that’s from a retrovirus protease that’s…
a protein… a retrovirus that’s related to HIV.
This is a case where… the experimentalists
had collected experimental data
but weren’t able to take that experimental data
and solve the structure
because they were missing some key pieces of information.
So, we set this up as a FoldIt puzzle
and the puzzle started with a model
which we knew was in the ballpark
but certainly wasn’t the correct structure,
and that’s shown in red on the left.
And FoldIt players formed teams,
and the teams…
they collaborate very closely together
within teams and compete with other teams
in a friendly sort of way.
So, these are… this is the result of a team,
and I’m gonna show you the results of three of the teammates.
So, the first teammate, named spvincent,
took the red model
and was able to find a lower energy structure,
which is shown in yellow.
Now, in these diagrams, blue is the actual…
the punchline is gonna be that FoldIt players solved the structure,
and that structure is shown in blue.
Of course, no one — we, neither…
we, nor the FoldIt players — knew what it was at the time they were doing this.
So, spvincent took the red model, got the yellow model, which was closer,
and then handed it off to his teammate, grabhorn,
and grabhorn produced the magenta structure,
and then finally grabhorn passed it off to mimi,
and mimi ran the final lap of the relay.
And you can see that mimi’s green structure
is much closer to the actual structure, in blue,
then was the starting structure
that’s in red on the far left.
And when we got mimi’s structure back,
we could see immediately that had to be the correct answer
because it fit beautifully the experimental data.
So, the data weren’t sufficient to determine what the structure is,
but they were enough… they were like a fingerprint…
you couldn’t tell what the person looked like from the fingerprint,
but you could tell it was the right person
when you had the fingerprint.
So, it’s just like that with the structure.
mimi’s structure fit the experimental data beautifully
and it was very, very exciting.
The second example I want to give you
is show you that FoldIt players
can actually come up with new algorithms.
So, I told you that there were these automated Rosetta algorithms —
that there were these buttons that you could click —
and FoldIt players…
we gave the FoldIt players the ability to create what we call recipes,
where… which are different combinations
of these automated algorithms.
And these recipes became very popular in the community
and many of them got to be very sophisticated.
This plot shows the time in weeks
from when we first released the capability to…
to make recipes.
Each vertical bar is the number of uses of a recipe
during that week,
and the different colors or shades
represent how many times each recipe was used.
So, some FoldIt players are very public-spirited
and they make their recipes generally available to the community,
and others like to keep them for themselves.
So, as you’d expect, the people who share get more uses.
And we noticed that in particular there were two recipes,
the one shown in red and the ones shown in green on this slide,
that were really becoming very, very popular in the community.
So, we were curious about what these were.
And I’m not gonna go through the details,
but the actual… the actual Rosetta…
the actual recipe for one of the most popular,
called Blue Fuse, is shown in the box.
And what we’re really stunned by
is that this Blue Fuse algorithm,
which was taking over the population,
was very, very similar to an algorithm
that we had been developing in the lab for this…
for the same problem, for protein structure prediction.
And I won’t go through the details of what it is,
but let’s just… but the colors
— the yellow, blue, and red —
are different operations.
And the algorithm we’d developed in the lab,
which is shown in the middle… the middle column, has…
you see this cycling between yellow, blue, and red,
yellow, blue, and red,
and what was… and we had never tried that before,
and it worked really, really well.
We were very excited about it.
And then we found that in the Blue Fuse algorithm that the players had developed,
it was very similar, alternating between these different operations.
And then we got… it was kind of sobering to find
that in the context of the game,
this Blue Fuse algorithm was actually better
than what we had developed as professional scientists in the lab.
So, the final example concerns a protein design.
And we have for many years
been designing new enzyme catalysts in the lab,
designing new proteins to catalyze reactions
which aren’t catalyzed by naturally occurring proteins.
And we do this by designing a protein,
using the methods described in my iBio seminar,
that holds the constituent chemicals
in just the right orientation for the chemical reaction to occur.
And when we make these proteins in the lab…
when they’re successful, what we find is
they actually catalyze the chemical reaction,
and that’s shown on the panel on the right here.
But what’s not so good about these designed catalysts
is the units on the x-axis.
Rather than seconds, which is what a naturally occurring enzyme
would take to catalyze a reaction,
this enzyme is a very bad one —
it takes hours to catalyze the chemical reaction.
So, when we looked at this design,
and we looked at the model of it, we saw that…
it’s sort of obvious what the problem is.
The two chemicals are shown in these full…
these ball-like figures in the middle.
And one of them is… the lower one is quite small,
and this designed catalyst does not
really hold onto these very extensively.
There’s not really a deep pocket that they fit into,
and so these chemicals really don’t bind very strongly
to the designed enzyme.
Now, there are these loops of the pro…
of the design that are coming out towards you that are in orange,
and it sort of seems like you might be able to change them
in some way to bind those substrates, those small molecules, better,
but it’s not really obvious to do… how to do that,
and you certainly couldn’t tell a computer to re…
to remodel the protein to bind the substrates better,
those small molecules.
But you can tell people that, so we asked the FoldIt community to do that,
and they came up with this solution shown in purple here,
where they built this whole new part of the protein
to come over and bind those small molecules better.
And what was really amazing when we went
and made this protein in the lab
is that it actually catalyzed the reaction
very, very much more rapidly — 20-fold more rapidly
than the starting design.
So, FoldIt players had figured out how to improve this design
that we had made on the computer.
And when the crystal structure was solved
in Barry Stoddard’s lab, of their design,
it turned out that it really folded up the way they predicted it to.
And you can see… the design is in purple —
that’s what the FoldIt players came up with —
and the crystal structure is in gold.
And again, it is very, very close.
What FoldIt players now have done very recently
I can call protein art.
It’s very beautiful.
In this… in this case, what they’ve done
is taken an extended protein chain and…
with no amino acid sequence on it,
and here the challenge is to fold it up and to put an amino acid sequence on it
so that it interacts in a very low energy way
with other identical copies of itself.
And so, these are very beautiful structures,
some of which resemble proteins which occur in nature
and others which look nothing like that.
For example, the one in the top left…
there’s no protein that looks anything like this.
So, we’re currently testing these brand-new proteins in the lab
and we’re very excited to see what the results will be.
And I’ve been very fortunate, again,
to have really talented collaborators,
both in the Biochemistry Department and in the Computer Science Department,
who are responsible for FoldIt.
And most importantly, I want to thank the FoldIt players,
who are really opening up this whole new area of scientific inquiry
and demonstrating that there’s kind of been a…
that these distinctions between scientists and the public, I think,
are a little bit artificial,
and that, really, anyone who’s interested
can become a participating… can participate in scientific research.
Thank you for your attention.